[Music]
the FBI's battle with Apple what's your
take i side with Apple on this one first
of all I've always been very related
close to human rights I'm one of the
founders of the e FF but aside aside
from that once countries can come in and
tell tell manufacturers you have to make
your products insecure computer security
is so important ever mint wants a
backdoor so that they can say look if we
really need to we can get in there and
see what was on this phone in case there
was any kind of nefarious activity and
you say what a lame case they picked the
lamest case you ever could the two
phones owned by the people that aren't
even convicted terrorists didn't have
one link to a terrorist organization
Verizon turned over all the phone
records all the SMS messages so they
want to take this other phone that they
didn't the two didn't destroy that was a
work phone it's so so lame and worthless
to expect something's on it right and
get Apple to expose it but boy I wrote a
couple times in my life I wrote
something could be a virus that could
have spread itself on Macintosh
computers forever and each time I threw
away every bit of code I'd written I was
so scared inside you do not want to let
something like that out and if you once
you create it there's a good chance
hackers will get into it and then what
if what if China says Apple you've got
to give us a backdoor so we can get into
any phone even your government officials
iPhones and inspect them anytime that's
wrong yeah security is an important
thing now look how many people get hurt
and millions of people's accounts get
exposed every day all right all right
you have me convinced I'm with you
[Applause]
you